[Music]
we want to understand better what is
human perception of the space while
we're moving through the abstract
environment
we would like to understand how do we
navigate in space how to be Orient in
space
[Music]
how can we transport science and the
fascination about it to everybody
foreign
[Music]
I'm a neuroscientist and a science
communicator and I'm the organizer and
host of Einstein in the dome when you
talk to scientists about his or her
project then you see that they really
burn they really have this enthusiasm
for that project and we wanted to
communicate this enthusiasm and we
thought that this this setting gives us
the best chances for this but event
series like this offered the opportunity
to show a layer audience what's the
what's the topic about and to also
afterwards get in touch with the
scientists ask them questions get
answers from them and this is I think
one of the most important things in
science apart from achieving results
so how can you turn a scientific talk
into a 360 degree immersive experience
you're taken in you kind of sucked into
the image you'd really dive into the
world into the ideas of the scientists
foreign
and you see the effect after the show
when the light goes on and you look into
faces like this in your cement you
really touch the people this is what we
try to do and I hope this is what we
accomplish but I'm sending the door
[Music]
I'm
a neuroscientist at the charity
University we started the project coffee
now as an interaction project between
neuroscience and architecture and of
course the topic where we both come
together a good intersection is space
how do we navigate in space how do we
Orient in space we live in more and more
complex Urban environments so we want to
use this immersive media to show
different spaces that's where
architecture comes in and we are going
to measure how we feel in such spaces
and this information would be used by
Architects to redesign spaces
foreign
[Music]
we would like to understand what are the
bottlenecks in special design how we
feel in space and probably we can come
up with better design better cities
better Urban spaces from this
information from neuroscience and make
cities of the future more accessible to
all kinds of people and more inclusive
design
it's a very basic question is is
physical space the same as virtual space
and research has shown that this is the
case so we can actually use this Dome as
a tool for studying interaction between
neuroscience and architecture for the
first time under this Dome we will show
you during our event how we intend to
measure brain activity and by that how
we can quantify how we are feeling in
space
[Music]
for me as an architect I want to
understand better what is the human
perception and in this field we want to
combine neuroscience and architecture
together in the field of the immersive
technology
[Music]
in our collaboration work we want to
understand better what is a human
perception of the space while we're
moving through the abstract environment
and we are asking ourselves if Urban
environment can be built around the
positive Human Experience
[Music]
in our studio we're using two and a half
meter projection dome for space creation
space presentation but at the same time
we want to understand patterns Place
perception and we used to work also with
VR but the VR experience limit us from
our physical body we cannot see
ourselves or we are presented in pure
virtual space as a virtual Avatar and in
the dome It's a combination of physical
and visa and digital world
foreign
[Music]
format is the most intensive and visual
impression for architectural and science
storytelling this is the first time we
are showing on a big screen on a big
platform like the Berlin planetarium our
work so we are very excited how this is
gonna go we think it's very important
and interesting so let's get engaged in
direct conversation
this is something really special when
you are really in the image in the
thought of the scientists and that makes
the show an unforgettable experience
[Music]
foreign